djs tengo 27 años
y creo que hago lo que me apasiona
es un deporte de potencia pero en verdad
todo cambia todo puede pasar en una
pista
yo creo que poder no el casco nos
transforma y obviamente poder nuestra
camisa de colombia que tengo es como
algo que uno sueña bacano tener como
compañeros que vibran con la misma
sensación de uno si podemos decir que
hacemos parte de la élite somos un país
que hemos tenido muy buenos resultados
mariana es una potencia perdida una
persona que desde chiquita está soñando
con ser el amor del mundo
había logrado ganar todo lo que hay por
ganar en hombres hemos logrado muchos
podemos votar tenemos en deuda que es la
gana de una copa mundo por lo más mi
caso he tenido segundo y tercero espero
no logrado como ganarme esa primera copa
mundo y obviamente es el primer
colombiano en hacerlo
usualmente entramos todos el domingo es
como el día de relajo todo depende de lo
que vayamos a ser esa semana muchas
después del gimnasio en la mañana y
piques en la tarde no la pizza
no estamos propensos a las caídas de
algo que para mí deporte y gracias no he
tenido algo muy grave para decirlo pero
tengo cinco cirugía en esa mano siento
que soy mucho mejor de lo que está en
río siento que puedo hacer unas muy
buenas cosas pero siento que todo
mejorar mucho más
tenemos ahora creo que con tres meses de
alrededor de tres meses de preparación
en tres meses de competencias en los
cuales día a día salen mejor y sé que
lograremos grandes cosas